はぁぁ
私は4歳からフェア挽くというスポーツを始めました
頭にヘアバンド足にはレッグウオーマーという格好で大流行した時代
母がインストラクターということもあって妹たちと一緒にな英語と一つとして楽しんで
いました
しかし小学2年生の時
咳や鼻水といった風邪の症状に加えて
夜中の12時1時
12時間おきに
トイレに起きては水岡を飲みするようになった方です
そんな症状は菌がいながら迎えた数字つ子の8歳の誕生日
私が楽しみにしていたのはパンダのケーキ
いざ食べようとすると吐き気がひどく
パンダの右耳のアズかの部分しか食べられませんでした
翌朝かかりつけの小児科で風邪薬を処方してもらうことにしました
診察を終え検査を終え待合室で待っていると
結果を伝えられた
うってきました
涙をこらえて
言葉を選んでいる
病気を説明してくれた
チャージャーの姿を
今も忘れられません
私は
1型糖尿病を発症しています
その後すぐに大きな病院に移動し2ヶ月加入引用しましたが
その当時の写真はありません
ところでみなさん
糖尿病には4つの種類があることをご存知でしょうか
1型糖尿病
2型糖尿病
二次性糖尿病
妊娠糖尿病
今日はこのうち1型糖尿病と2型糖尿病の2つについて説明したいと思います
皆さんがよくメディアでに聞きする糖尿病は正式には2型糖尿病と言います
私が発症者糖尿病は1型糖尿病と言います
これらの違いはこのようによっています
2型糖尿病は
遺伝や生活習慣の乱れが原因で発症します
発祥は成人に多いですが医原性が高く
最近では小学生で発症したり
日本人の成人5人に1人が不の発症リスクを持っていると言われています
それに対して1型糖尿病は
発祥の詳しいメカニズムは未だにわかっていません
子供の糖尿病と思われがちですが
年齢に関係なく
突然発症します
人間は食事をして
ブドウ糖 in 3んが細胞に運んでくれることでエネルギーを作っています
その大切な働きをするインスリンが
なぜか突然
でない体になってしまいました
私たち1型糖尿病の患者は
毎日インスリンを体に入れないと
死ぬんです
ではどうやって体に入れると思いますか
ご存知の方もいるかもしれませんが
患者の多くは
インスリンを注射します
こんな子供たちもまた
毎日し5回
食事や寝る前に
自分自身で注射を打っています
彼女たちが支えているのは
物理的な痛みだけではありません
糖尿病に対する
五和や偏見による
精神的な痛みもまた
抱えています
私が学校生活に戻ってまず最初に困ったのはインスリン注射をする場所でした
中には人のいない教室やトイレに隠れて注射をする人もいます
私はなるべく病気に増えてほしくないん
そんな想いと
衛生面から
保健室デー
隠れてこっそり注射を打っていました
でも保健室には他の子もいるんです
注射うっていうのを見つかってからは毎日のように
痛くないの
されていました
説明をしても次の日には違う子が来て今日見本に行ってきます
まるで偽物語家にいるような気持ちがして
私は説明することをやめてしまいました
そんな私を救ってくれたの小学校5年生の時の担任の先生です
先生は私を私自身が病気をオープンにすることができれば
もっと楽に学校生活が送れるのではないかと考え
カミングアウトの手助けをしてくれました
それまで私は私が悪何か悪いことをして病気を発症したわけではないのですが
何か悪いことをしているような
そしても後ろめたい気持ちで
注射をしています
カミングアウトができて注射をクラス打てるようになった時
それまでの私の日常は180度変わりました
そんな精神的な変化はその後競技に移行しさ
エアロビックでも現れました
中学生の時には憧れだった全日本選手権に当時の史上最年少記録で
出場することができ自信をつけました
そして日本一
さらには世界乗務狙って頑張っていこうという気持ちが沸き起こってきました
そんなとき一人のドクターとであります
今でも筋としてお世話になっているそのドクターは糖尿病の専門医であるだけではなく
ご自身も1型糖尿病です
ご自身の経験に基づいて
私の生活に合った
治療法提案いただき
トレーニングの効果も構造しました
おかげで高校1年生の時には
ジュニアの
世界チャンピオンに2度輝くことができました
大人の部門に上がってからも日本代表として
世界を転戦することができ
病気を持っていても
山にでも挑戦できるそんなことを証明していきました
引退した今は大会の解説や
日本エアロビック連盟の理事として a
エアロビックの普及発展に努めています
2010年からは
患者家族の支援団体認定 npo 法人日本 iddm ネットワークで
患者の声を知る1人として活動をしています
こう団体は阪神淡路大震災で
in 水の供給に困った肝臓な家族が中心となってスタートしました
患者会によくある相談対応や
病気の啓発といった活動の他に力を入れている
特徴的な活動があります
それは
1型糖尿病
治る病気にする研究を支援していることです
2005年に立ち上げた1型糖尿病研究基金は
これまでに48件
合計で約2億5000万円の研究費を支援してきました
しかし
1型糖尿病治る病気にするには
100億の研究費が必要だと言われています
私たちが支援した研究の中で最も期待されている研究の一つに
バイオ人口膵島移植というものがあります
これは患者が陰線注射をしなくても生きられる
つまり
病気が治る未来を目指した研究です
移植用の豚からインスリンが出る細胞を取り出し
拒絶反応を抑えるための特殊なカプセルでつつに点滴などで移植します
海外でも臨床試験が始められているこの研究を日本で実現するために
私たちは
4つは研究機関に支援をしました
国立国際医療研究センター
明治大学
京都府立大学
福岡大学
これらの四つの研究機関に協力し合ってもらい
研究が進められています
少しずつですが
1型糖尿病が治る未来を
近づけられていると感じています
そんな風に今は前向きにこの病気と迎えあっていられる私ですが
小学6年生の時
嫌になっていっ
注射を打たない時期がありました
実は稀に治る
スポーツをやっている人はインスになって打たなくていい
そんな根も葉もないような誤差を飲みに者のです
当時は4回だった注射の打ち給食前の駐車を抜いていました
友達の収集車売ったのという心配する声かけに
打ったよと
嘘をついていました
結果ダイエットもしていないのに体脂肪率は4%まで激減し
骨と皮状態になりました
とにかく無気力と眠気がひどく
みんなが練習している後ろで休んでいたり
練習が終わると
こいつになだれ込むようにして寝てしまい
親がどんどんとん
ドアを叩かなければ出てこれない状態まで陥ってみました
幸いにも私は
隠していたインスリンを母らにつけてくれたおかげで
生者売っていない事を気づいてもらいました
もしあの時気づかれず
注射を抜いていたり
当時は4回だった注射の家
ヒョン回全てを
歌が買ったとしたら
私は今日
この舞台に立っておりません
2015年にはこんなこともありました
とつい気に
1型糖尿病の7歳の男の子がいました
男の子は注射を打つ毎日をとても嫌がり
その後両親はそんな息子をどうにかして作ってあげたい
頭を悩まれていたそうです
そんな時に
インスリンは必要ない
インスには毒だ
などと言う人は死んであってしまい
妊娠中車
出してしまいました
注射を打たなくて良い毎日を
男はここは
とても喜んだそうです
でも
なってしまった
陰線をいただければ死んでしまう
そんなことを
funny 祖母にもが入っていたのです
巨税 new になってされています
でも退院後
2注射を打たない
毎日を選んでしまっ
やはりの声が届かなへ
そんな状態まで陥った表紙んよ
2人が攻めることができますか
なぜこんなことが起こるのか
それは
この病気が治らないから
だからわたしは
1型糖尿病を
治る病気にしたいのです
私も
1型糖尿病です
今日も
2000注射を
2回打っていっ
この舞台に
上がっています
今からを取ります
[拍手]
me
[音楽]
真相応募ピンッ
me
tee
dj
ん
ana ああああ
[音楽]
ん
[拍手]